[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
الجامعه العربيه تشكل لجنه اتصال للحوار
المباشر مع سوريا ودعواته لانهاء الازمه
السوريه سياسيا
القوى المدنيه السودانيه تطالب بالتدخل
الفوري لوقف الحرب بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريعه
اوكرانيا تقول ان روسيا لم تعد قادره على
شن هجوم خطير عليها ومؤسس فاغنر يشير
لبقاء قواته في باخمه
اذا مشاهدينا البدايه من اجتماع وزراء
الخارجيه العرب بشان قرار عوده سوريا الى
جامعه الدول العربيه قضى القرار بتشكيل
لجنه وزاريه مكونه من السعوديه الاردن
ومصر والعراق ولبنان والامين العام
لمتابعه تنفيذ بيان عمان والاستمرار
بالحوار المباشر مع دمشق طبعا كانت مراسله
العربيه قالت انها وزراء الخارجيه العرب
اتفقوا على عوده مشروطه لسوريا الى جامعه
الدول العربيه القرار الصادر بعد اجتماع
ووزراء الخارجيه العرب قضب استئناف مشاركه
الوفود السوريه في اجتماعات مجلس الجامعه
وايضا جميع المنظمات والاجهزه التابعه لها
وذلك اعتبارا من اليوم القرار اكد على
ضروره اتخاذ خطوات عمليه وفاعله للتدرج
نحو حل الازمه السوريه وفق مبدا الخطوه
مقابل الخطوه القرار جدد الالتزام بالحفاظ
على سياده سوريا ووحده اراضيها حيث رحب
بالبيانات الصادره عن اجتماعي جده
وعمان بشان سوريا خلال الاسابيع الاخيره
اتخذت الدول العربيه قرارا باستئناف
مشاركه وفد الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في
اجتماعات مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه وجميع
المنظمات والاجهزه التابعه لها اعتبارا من
اليوم 7 مايو 2023
اكرر مجددا على ضروره وفاء كل من الحكومه
السوريه والقوه الوطنيه والمكونات السوريه
والمجتمع الدولي والدول المعنيه بالازمه
بالتزاماتها كل اتجاه الاخر
قبل ذلك قال ايضا ان الحسم العسكري في
سوريا امر غير واقعي دعا الى ايجاد تسويه
سياسيه للازمه دعونا نتابع السبيل الوحيد
للتسويه هو الحل السياسي بملكيه سوريه
خالصه دون املاءات خارجيه
واستيفاء الاجراءات المرتبطه بتحقيق
التوافق الوطني بين الاشقاء السوريين
وبناء الثقه ومواصله اجتماعات اللجنه
الدستوريه على نحو يتمشى مع المرجعيات
الدوليه وقرار مجلس الامن رقم 22 54
وبما يلبي تطلعات الشعب السوري ويحقق
اماله المشروعه في غد افضل
ويضمن الحفاظ على وحده سوريا وسيادتها
وسلامتها الاقليميه وعروباتها
وينهي كل مظاهر التدخلات الخارجيه في
شؤونها بما في ذلك الاعتداءات على اراضيها
ومن جانبه قال الامين العام للجامعه
العربيه احمد ابو الغيط قال ان قرار اعاده
سوريا للجامعه العربيه لا يعني اعاده
الدول العربيه لعلاقاتها مع سوريا مشيرا
الى ان هذا القرار سيادي وتتخذه كل دوله
عوده سوريا الى شغل المقعد
هي بدايه حركه وليست نهايه مطاف بمعنى انه
مسار التسويه للازمه السوريه هتاخذ مرحله
من الاجراءات والتدرج فيها ومهمه هذه
اللجنه هي متابعه هذه
الاجراءات ايضا هي ليس
بقرار
لاقامه علاقات طبيعيه بين الدول العربيه
وسوريا هذا قرار سيادي لكل دوله على حدى
نحن نتحدث في هذا القرار عن
شغل المقعد وتشكيل اللجنه للتواصل مع
الحكم في سوريا
وفي اول رد فعل لها قالت وزاره الخارجيه
السوريه انها تلقت باهتمام قرار عودتها
الى الجامعه العربيه اضافت الخارجيه
السوريه ان المرحله المقبله تتطلب نهجا
عربيا فاعلا وشددت على اهميه العمل
العربيه المشترك والحوار للتصدي للتحديات
التي تواجه المنطقه على كل المزيد معنى في
الاستوديو الكاتب الصحفي السوري حنا حوشان
اهلا بك استاذ حنا اسمح لي ان ابدا
بقراءتك للبيان الختامي
بصراحه هذا هذا الموقف الذي اتخذته اليوم
في الجامعه العربيه بوقف تجميد عضويه
سوريا في الجامعه العربيه هو
قرار مهم منتظر في سوريا كثيرا دعيني
يتكلم عن الشان الانساني اليوم اذا كنا
نعتبر ان القرار هو بمثابه خطوه عقوبات
كانت من قبل الجامعه العربيه في نوفمبر من
عام 2011
العقوبات اليوم قد توقفت وهذا اليوم رجل
الشارع ينتظر المزيد وينتظر بصراحه رفع
العقوبات الامريكيه وينتظر موقف من الدول
العربيه لكي تقف مع سوريا اليوم في مواجهه
الدور الذي يمكن ان يتخذ خطا اذا ما اخذنا
بعين الاعتبار ما جاء في طيات التصريحات
عوده
عوده لسوريا في هذا المقعد لا تعني عوده
العلاقات الكامله مع الدول العربيه
كما قال الامين العام للجامعه انه هذا
قرار سيادي واعتقد يعني بعد
تقريبا بعد تقريبا اكثر من
11 سنه او 12 سنه من التجميد العضويه
سوريا اليوم سوريا نفسها اليوم يعني دعيني
اقول لك ان اليوم اثبتت انه
العلاقات الثنائيه العربيه
يعني اهم من موقف الجامعه ولو ان للموقف
الجامعه العربيه دور يعني له كثير من
الاهميه هذا القرار الذي اتخذ اليوم
نعم وطيب له اهميه ولكن كيف يمكن له ان
يطبقوا طبيعه الشروط او الاشتراطات او
مبدا الخطوه مقابل الخطوه التي نتحدث عنه
مبدا الخطوه مقابل خطوه يعني الكثير من
الاشخاص يعتقدون انه هي
امور شرطيه
اعتقد ان سوريا مثلا اليوم في موضوع
اللاجئين وهذا اهم بند قد تساهلت كثيرا
فتحت معابر ابان تذكرين بسته فبراير زلزال
ومن بعدها اصلا بدات الامور تتحسن بعض
الشيء بين الدول العربيه
من ذلك الوقت سوريا قدمت بهذا الشان بما
يتعلق بموضوع اللاجئين دخول اللاجئين دخول
المساعدات
التي يمكن ان نضعها على الطاوله عندك
تواجد
لاكثر من دوله في المنطقه في سوريا ان
كانت على المستوى الاقليمي او على المستوى
الدولي وهذا موضوع كبير ربما بس عندي سؤال
فيما يتعلق بهذه المبادره الان خاصه انك
ذكرت انه العلاقات الثنائيه ربما تكون
اقوى من العوده الى الجامعه ولكن في نفس
الوقت كوننا نتحدث عن انه هاي مجرد خطوه
اولى وحراك اولي وليس نهايه المطاف ما
الذي سينعكس على الاخر ستبقى العلاقات
الثنائيه هي المحرك او انه لا ربما هذه
اللجنه والدول المشاركه لها ستكون لها فعل
على الارض بالنهايه تقدم
اليوم حتى يعني بهذا القرار الذي اتخذ
اليوم هناك بعض الانقسام تعلمين ان هناك
مثلا
ثلاث او اربع دول لها الى حد ما تحفظ
تجاهه يعني اعاده شغل سوريا لمقعدي هذا
الجامعه العربيه لكن يعني
كما ذكرت لك سوريا تعول كثيرا على
العلاقات الثنائيه وهناك كما تعلمين في
الجامعه العربيه وبالنسبه للدول العربيه
يعني هناك دول اعمده اليوم تقريبا عندما
نتحدث عن دول اعمده الجامعه العربيه
تقريبا اليوم يعني ما في دول من الاعمده
لحتى تحفظ على عوده سوريا وهذا شيء يبشر
بالتالي لان طبعا التطورات ونرى الى اين
ستتجه الامور شكرا جزيلا لك حنا حوشان
الكاتب الصحفي السوري على هذه المعلومات
انا مع هذا الاجراء انه يرجع المقعد
السوري يعني بضل العرب هو الدول العربيه
هن العمق الحقيقي لسوريا هي سوريا كانت
على طول يعني جزء من هاي الامه جزء من هذا
الوطن فانا مبسوط يعني انه ترجع العلاقات
يعني وما في شيء ما بيتصلح يعني كله
بيتصلح طبعا
مبسوطين يعني كتير وبنتمنى لانه سوريا
يعني هي من المؤسسين للجامعه العربيه
والجهود العربيه اللي عم تبذل يعني خاصه
كمان الاردن كتير اله دور وعم بتحاول
كتير منيح وبنتمنى ترجع للجامعه العربيه
ويرجعوا يعني الصف العربي
جامعه الدول العربيه وامر كتير مفرح
بسموريين وهذا الامر خلينا نتفائل لانه ان
شاء الله يكون في حلول للمشاكل للملف
السوري او حتى ياثر على مستوى المنطقه
يعني بكل المجالات السياسيه وحتى وان شاء
الله يعود هذا الموضوع بالنفق الاقتصادي
ونلاحظ تاثيره كمان علينا بشكل مباشر
ويكون
بادره كويسه نحل كل المشاكل العربيه وهذا
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات الوضع في السودان والتي كانت
ايضا حاضره ضمن اجتماع وزراء الخارجيه
العرب بالقاهره وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح
شكري اعلن عن تشكيل لجنه اتصال ايضا عربيه
خاصه بالسودان لوقف القتال وايضا لضمان
سلامه الممرات الامنه في البلاد نتابع
هناك اهميه وضروره بالغه للتحرك العربي
السريحه ومن هنا جاء قرار انشاء لجنه
اتصال من بين اعضاء الجامعه العربيه
تهدف لوقف اطلاق النار والسماح بالممرات
الانسانيه لاحتياجات المدنيين والحفاظ على
مؤسسات الدوله وعدم تعريضها للخطر
الانهيار الذي يهددها حاليا
ميدانيا في السودان ورغم دعوات التهدئه
افاد مراسل العربيه في الخرطوم بان
اشتباكات دارت في منطقه القصر الرئاسي بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع تصاعدت
اعمده الدخان الميراث الاضاف انه تم سماع
اصوات لاطلاق النار في محيط ايضا مطار
الخرطوم محيط قياده الجيش حيث اطلقت قوات
الدعم السريع مضادات ارضيه على طائرات
الجيش هذا ياتي في وقت يعقد فيه ممثلو
اطراف الصراع محادثات في السعوديه لوضع حد
للاقتتال الداخلي المستمر منذ ثلاثه
اسابيع في السودان
وفي هذه الاثناء بدات الاصوات السياسيه في
السودان تنادي لوقف الحرب تلقى الامين
العام للجامعه العربيه احمد ابو الغيط
رساله من الاطراف الموقعه على الاتفاق
الاطار تطلب منه التدخل فورا لوقف المعارك
الاطراف المدنيه بحسب بيان للجامعه
العربيه طلبوا بالتواصل مع قيادات الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع
ودعوتهما لوقف الحرب ورفض التدخلات
الخارجيه ودعم العمليه السياسيه والمشاركه
فيها فضلا عن تسهيل وصول المساعدات
الانسانيه للمتضررين
المزيد معنا من الخرطوم الصحفي عمار ابو
شيبه اهلا بك عمار اخر التطورات
الميدانيات تفضل عمار
اهلا بك واهلا بالمشاهدين الكرام اخر
التطورات الميدانيه بعد هدوء نسبه وحذر
كان قبل اكثر من ساعتين من الان قبل دقائق
اعاده طائرات سلاح الجو للجيش السوداني
لتنفيذ هجمات واهداف عسكريه على الارض
لقوات الدعم السريع بحسب مصادر تحدثنا
اليها في مدينه ام درمان في محيط الاذاعه
والتلفزيون وفي محيط ايضا كذلك مدينه بحري
في حي شمبات
وحيئه الصافيه وحي البراحه
وحي كافوري وهذه مناطق تنتشر فيها قوات
الدعم السريع
بكثافه في مدينه الخرطوم هنا في وسط
العاصمه كنا نستمع قبل قليل لدوي انفجارات
في محيط القصر الرئاسي
ومحيط مطار الخرطوم وبحسب ايضا معلومات
وردت الينا بان الجيش نفذ هجمات جويه
وطلعات جويه على منطقه شرق النيل
وهذه المنطقه ايضا تتمركز فيها قوات الدعم
السريع ما يعني ان الجيش الان يستخدم سلاح
الجو بكثافه وترد قوات الدعم السريع من
خلال المضادات الارضيه باعتبارها تنتشر في
هذه الاراضي وهذه الشوارع الكبيره هذا هو
الوضع من الخرطوم الصحفي عمار ابو شيبه
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
وفي هذه الاثناء وجه العاهل السعودي الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز وولي العهد الامير
محمد بن سلمان وجهها مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه بتقديم مساعدات انسانيه متنوعه
بقيمه 100 مليون دولار لصالح الشعب
السوداني كما وجه الملك سلمان والامير
محمد بن سلمان بتنظيم حمله شعبيه عبر منصه
ساهم وذلك لتخفيف اثار الاوضاع التي يمر
بها الشعب السوداني حاليا
والى تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا رئيس
المخابرات العسكريه الاوكرانيه كيريلو
بودانوب اكد ان روسيا لم تعد قادره على شن
اي هجوم خطير على بلاده وبرر بودانوف ذلك
لعدم امتلاك روسيا الامكانات العسكريه
والاقتصاديه والسياسيه للقيام بعملياتها
العسكريه بحسب تعبيره اضاف ايضا ان روسيا
تسعى لتقديس مخزونها من الصواريخ لتجهيزها
لتعطيل الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
ومع ترقب غربي للهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاد
يبدو ان التوقعات الغربيه والتي وصفتها
بالمبالغ فيها بحسب واشنطن بوست تضعيف تحت
ضغوط تتمثل في ان تلجا اوكرانيا حاله ما
فشلت في هجومها الى مفاوضات او على الاقل
تراجع الدعم العسكري الغربي السخي لها منذ
بدء الصراع بحسب الصحيفه فان واشنطن
وحلفائها تعتبر هذا الهجوم اختبارا حاسما
لمعرفه ما اذا كانت الاسلحه والتدريب
والذخيره التي ارسلت يمكن ان تترجم الى
مكاسب على الارض الهجوم بات وشيكا ويمثل
نقطه فارقه بالنسبه لكيف وبينما تسعى كييف
لاستعاده السيطره على اراضي ضمتها موسكو
فضلا طبعا عن اثبات انها تستحق استمرار
الدعم من الغرب يتبع الرئيس بوتين وقواته
جدولا زمنيا اطول وذلك بعيدا عن الضغوط
السياسيه المحليه رغم معاناه بلاده من
قيود الغرب الاقتصاديه وايضا العسكريه
ربما اشكاليه سيد الكرملين الاكثر الحاحا
الان هي تصاعد الخلافات بين باجنر والقاده
العسكريين الروس ما يهدد قدره موسكو على
مواجهه الهجوم المضاد على الارض مؤسس
مجموعه فاديناريا بروجين قال قد هدد
بالاحرى بالانسحاب من خط المواجهه في
باخموت بسبب نقص الذخيره التي لن تمكنه من
مواصله القتال قبل ان يعود ويؤكد انه تلقى
وعودا بالحصول على ذخائر واسلحه قريبا
[موسيقى]
وحول الانتخابات التركيه عقد رئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان اكبر تجمع حاشد ضمن حملته
الانتخابيه في اسطنبول قبل انتخابات مقرره
في الرابع عشر من مايو الجاري وصفت
بالحاسمه صحيفه التايمز اعتبرت ان
الانتخابات معلقه على حافه الهاويه
متسائله عما اذا كان زمن الرئيس الحالي
رجب طيب اردوغان قد انتهى يتسابق اردوغان
على راس حزب العداله والتنميه وكمال
كالجدار اوغلو على راس حزب الشعب الجمهوري
للفوز في تلك الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
في الانتخابات التركيه ينظر الى كليجدار
جلو على انه فرس رهان في تلك الانتخابات
طبعا بحسب صحيفه التايمز البريطانيه لاول
مره منذ 20 عاما يواجه اردوغان باحتمال
الخساره حتى في معقله القديم طرابزون من
المتوقع ان يتراجع الدعم الذي كان يتحصل
عليه اردوغان عاده رغم انه لازال يحظى
بدعم ضخم بين قواعده الانتخابيه حيث ينظر
اليه كرجل دوله لكن شعبيه اردوغان تاثرت
بعوامل عده من بينها نهجه الاقتصادي فضلا
عن تعامل حكومته مع الزلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب البلاد في فبراير الماضيه ناهيك طبعا
عن شعور متنامن بان اردوغان بدا يفقد
بريقه لفتت الصحيفه الى ان ارتفاع تكاليف
المعيشه بات يغطي على كل شيء حيث سجلت
معدلات التضخم ارتفاعا بلغت نسبته 85% تمت
عنصر اخر مؤثر في هذا السباق الانتخابي هو
ان حوالي خمس الناخبين الاتراك هم دون سن
ال 25 عام ولم يسبق لنحو نصف هذا العدد
التصويت من قبل فيما تشير استطلاعات الراي
الى ان نسبه كبيره من هؤلاء الناخبين
الجدد تعارض نظام الحكم الذي ينتهجه
اردوغان
على كل من تجمع الرئيس اردوغان للانتخابي
في اسطنبول ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
زيدان زنجلو اهلا بك زيدان انقل لنا اخر
المعلومات المتوفره لديك
[موسيقى]
ساحاول
الى انصار
التجمع
مليون و700 الف شخص حضروا الى هذا
التركيه يسجل
عدد
الاشخاص الذين حضروا في تجمع
تركيا هو كما قلت في نشرات قوه بين
المرشحين كمال اوروبا يوم
[موسيقى]
كمال امس وزعماء الطاوله السداسيه بالعموم
هذا هو استعراض هو في اكبر
مدينه اكبر كتله انتخابيه في
تركيا قوه اقتصاديه في تركيا هنا في
اسطنبول وهي كما يقال انها بيضه القبان
ومن يحاكم حسب العداله والتنميه منذ
الاسابيع الطويله يحاول التجليز لهذا
الحدث الهام في محاوله
الرئيس اردوغان الانتخابي في اسطنبول كان
معنى مراسل العربيه زيدان ونحن مشاهدينا
استثنائيا في الخامسه اليوم ننهي هذه
النشره الان وذلك لاعطاء الوقت للاقتصاد
لمناقشه الميزانيه السعوديه نلتقي غدا
ونشره كامله للخامسه مشاهدينا
ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات